Chelsea gabbard is a former presidential
candidate reign as a Democrat joins us
tonight to assess
Congressman thank you so much for coming
on so here you had the progressives in
the party the Liberals acting like
liberals have acted for like 100 years
and saying maybe we should and I want to
say I agree with him completely we
should try to get a peace forged before
we all die and then they have to retract
it why
yeah you're exactly right uh Tucker
these so-called progressives did a very
simple thing that apparently can appear
to be brave in Washington these days and
that letter to President Biden they just
told the truth about how this ongoing
proxy war with Russia is increasing in
costs and consequences both on the
Ukrainian people but also the American
people here at home and how it's
negatively impacting gas prices
increasing inflation and so on uh you
know these progressives in the letter
they didn't say stop sending Aid to
Ukraine now all they said was hey
President Biden engage in diplomacy and
the response they got of course from the
war mongers who controlled the Democrat
Party in Washington was to immediately
be smashed to Pieces so much so that
these Democrat members of Congress
coward in the corner with fear and now
have gone so far out of their way
apologizing profusely for having the
audacity to call for diplomacy in this
war that's putting us all at risk and
now they've actually gone 180 degrees in
the opposite direction they're now
trying to prove how much of a war
monger's they too are by saying no don't
engage in diplomacy we don't want you to
do that this is exactly Tucker one of
the main reasons I left the Democrat
Party they are completely controlled by
these war mongers in Washington they
don't really care about the Ukrainian
people otherwise they would have engaged
in diplomacy many many months ago they
don't really care about the American
people who are struggling uh just to
just to make ends meet struggling with
inflation struggling with increasing
costs of just about everything and it
just shows who they are subservient to
the military-industrial complex and the
War Hawks in the Democrat Party and the
mainstream media
I mean it's why they basically kicked
you out of the party because you said
well maybe we shouldn't bomb all the
Christians in Syria maybe there's
another way no that was like this is
their Red Line it's War why is that and
did you know that when you went into
Congress
no uh the the Democrats that I saw the
Democrats uh leaders that I saw were
people who took a stand for peace who
people uh like my former boss uh senator
akaka from Hawaii he had served during
World War II he understood the cost of
War to see how so completely where even
these so-called progressives you know
they claimed in the past at least to be
the champions for peace to be people who
understood that in order to be
prosperous and free we must be at peace
now that's still true we still cannot
achieve prosperity and freedom unless we
have peace but now everyone in the
Democrat Party in the leadership in
Washington is walking in lockstep as War
Hawks no one daring to even step outside
the line and say hey diplomacy let's
exercise diplomacy what cowards what
cowards they are Joseph gabbard
appreciate your coming on as always hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else